[Music]
foreign
you are watching The Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with the journalist
and broadcaster Jenny kleeman and the pr
consultant Alex Dean they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight so
let's see what's on some of those front
pages for you now well the Metro leads
with record-breaking figures from the
office for National statistics
suggesting that 2.5 million people in
the UK are too sick to work
on that same story the male has the
headline working from home fuels UK's
sick note crisis
according to the express Rishi sunak is
making the case for reforming the
European Court of Human Rights power to
block British deportation flights to
Rwanda
the guardian reports that ministers are
considering removing basic housing
protections from Asylum seekers in a
drive to get them out of hotels
the eye has news of two new cases of
bird flu in the UK but says that there's
no evidence of human to human
transmission
the financial times carries comments
from the chief executive of the
artificial intelligence firm chat GPT
who's told the US Congress he's worried
AI could be used to disrupt next year's
American elections
the times reports on secure starmer
vowing to make labor the party of house
building by relaxing planning
restrictions and allowing more homes to
be built on the green belt
and the star warns its readers not to
use cheeky emojis when looking for love
online
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we are joined tonight by Jenny
cleeman and Alex Dean welcome to both of
you let us start with the metro and
their bold headline 2.5 million
sick notes um to what is this being
attributed Jenny
well this is being attributed to the
pandemic the sick notes uh that are
being handed in are for conditions like
uh back pain neck pain poor mental
health post-viral fatigue and anyone who
uh has spent the past few years hunched
over a kitchen table a laptop display uh
we'll know that it's not very good for
your neck and back it's also not very
good for your mental health to be living
as so many of us have been living for
for the past few years and the thing is
um we are all still getting over the
pandemic there is still very much a
hangover from the pandemic of of uh
working from home there is also
post-viral fatigue of people who had it
who are dealing with living with covid
and you know there have been big changes
to the way we work I remember the good
old days when Alex and I were allowed in
the studio but now we're all worth
punched in front of our laptops uh but
yes these are really serious figures of
every uh it's something like one in for
every 13 people in a job one is unable
to work
um because of long-term sickness we have
NHS backlogs waiting lists that mean for
certainly for mental health problems
um it takes a very long time for people
who are ill with these conditions to be
seen for these conditions to be tackled
and at a time when uh the leader of both
parties is saying that the key to us
getting out of the financial crisis that
we're in is growth economic growth the
idea that one in 13 of the workforce is
unable to work because of long-term
sickness
um is really worrying
Alex how worried should we be by these
uh these figures it's up four hundred
thousand um since the pandemic
yeah quite significantly I I think not
least because
um everything Jenny just said was
correct about the way we view uh
economic performance another way of
looking at it is that we've always been
less productive as a country than we
would like to be certainly for the last
two decades well before coronavirus
we've been complaining about our lack of
productivity uh a a comparative lack of
increased productivity as a country and
this kind of thing just sets the needle
on that way back but you know Julian
there's one other thing about this we've
had all manner of people lifestyle gurus
uh to Leading Chief Executives extolling
the virtues of working from home as a
new liberating life choice it may be
that there's a sting in the tail about
that and we're seeing that play out now
as as Jenny rightly says the conditions
that people are talking about in all of
the newspapers today are things like
neck ache and backache things that are
very often caused by sitting in
inappropriate conditions for prolonged
periods of time you're not getting up
and talking to your colleagues you're
not going to another meeting room you're
not coming to and fro you're sitting at
your table or at your desk all day long
and who knew it turns out it's bad for
you but generally do people like working
from home though Jenny or at least want
the option to be able to to choose
I think very much so and some of what
what came out in the reporting today
about this is that people are are
productive when they work from home by
some accounts they are more productive
and I read something today saying that
it doesn't stifle creativity which I
think is is very strange because I don't
think it's very conducive to creativity
to be going back-to-back meetings but
yes people want the flexibility of being
able to work from home and now that
they've seen that it's possible
um they want to make sure that that can
continue but yeah you know we have to
make sure that we're doing it in a way
that doesn't make people suffer
physically and mentally and actually
drilling down on some of the detail on
these figures it's it's very interesting
that it's younger people who um are
living with mental health problems that
prevent them from working it's older
people who are off sick because of heart
conditions and back and neck conditions
we have to we have to think about this
if this is now a fact of how how we live
we need to be able to address these
issues the same way that an employer or
HR would look at your setup in the
office and make sure it was optimal
they're going to need to think about
your setup as of working from home and
making sure that you're guessing what
you're what you need in order to be
mentally and physically healthy and Alex
uh according to the mail which reminds
us that part of the the story is people
dealing with the effects of long covet
yeah that's a very fair point the last
piece of the puzzle is those and
probably most of your viewers will know
at least one person who's suffering from
uh long covid
um part of the challenge for those
trying to work out the future of our
economy is how long long covid is we
talk about trying to attract retirees
back to recent retirees back to work we
talk about the difference in you know
changing pension arrangements to lure
surgeons coming back those things are
quantifiable how long will long covid be
a condition is it I mean heaven forbid
is it the rest of your life
um or is it something that someone gets
better from over time gradually I
certainly know both sufferers and
employers will be hoping that it's the
latter that people recover from kovid
over time and we'll see people back and
healthy at work yeah still unanswered
questions uh still with with covid
aren't there let's move on to the
express and this story with the Prime
Minister well he's probably on his way
back now from Iceland but but they're
really pushing for
greater powers for deportation and um
making his case to the the EU
Jenny well yeah he was talking at a
meeting with the Council of Europe and
it was about these uh deep implication
orders these uh these and Trauma orders
they're called
um it's uh trying to stop the the um
these I think they're called Rule 39.
it's used to block Depot flights at the
last minute and they're called pajama
orders because judges get woken up in
the middle of the night and uh told that
they must stop these flights through
Orlando because they contravene the
European convention on human rights uh
Rishi sunak uh wants us to be able to uh
to get around this and to be able to
deport people to Rwanda I mean I feel
very uneasy about this I think it's a
slippery slope when you start opting out
of certain amounts of Human Rights human
rights legislation I think the European
convention on human rights is incredibly
important and we were instrumental in in
setting it up and uh so when I see
things like this I always think oh you
know we're better than this we we
shouldn't have to change human rights
laws in order to uh protect our borders
but that's clearly not what the
government thinks there are many other
things on the agenda
um at Council of Europe meeting
um and not least of which Ukraine but
this is what Rishi sunak is is really
pushing for I think hit that his
spokespeople were saying that he had
some success some just some traction at
these talks although obviously uh some
of the leaders there certainly uh some
some leaders from the Icelandic
delegation was saying that they had no
interest in in changing uh rule 39 at
all yes we read that the Prime Minister
uh told the group that his government
would not rest until we stop the boat so
I'm so very emphatic about the the
message and the the changes that perhaps
he wants to see Alex
yeah you talked about it at the
beginning of that as if it was in a EU
story of course this is the European
Court of human rights in Strasbourg
which is not related to our membership
of the past membership of the European
Union albeit a lot of the decision
makers are the same so it may appear to
be a distinction uh without a difference
but it's not um an EU body it's not the
ecj and actually I think if you look at
the headlines we're talking about here
um even those people who disagree with
the prime minister's position and the
government's position about deportation
to Rwanda might might be willing to
concede that he's got a point about
procedure and process because in the
hearings that we're talking about as
this front page that we've been seeing
uh sets out uh the hearings are one set
late at night with almost no notice of
the member states concerned and two are
the papers pejorative terms secret well
let's uh just agree that they're closed
that is to say it's not open and
transparent Justice in a way that people
would expect issues of genuine substance
his policy difference to be debated so
actually I think the Prime Minister may
have more friends on that point Than
People expect even if people go on to
disagree with him on the substance about
uh whether or not you should be able to
send people to Rwanda I think the
process by which an international Court
tells a member state that signed up to
it that they've got something wrong the
idea that process should be transparent
is I think something a lot of people can
agree with
Jenny take us into this story in the
guardian
um saying that ministers are to remove
basic housing protections from Asylum
Seekers under new rules designed to to
move tens of thousands out of hotels
yes the guardian has got wind or some
plans put forward by the housing
secretary Michael Gove and the Home
Secretary stuella bravaman uh to allow
um private landlords to house Asylum
Seekers and they will not have to
register they wouldn't need to have HMO
licenses they wouldn't have to register
with local authorities and this would
give them exemptions from certain rules
electrical safety rules minimum room
side sizes and this is of course because
of the pressure of the cost of housing
so many thousands of Asylum seekers in
hotels
um I would argue that the answer to that
is to process them quickly and to deal
with the backlog in the home office not
to uh to subject people who are seeking
asylum in this country to housing
standards that are that are lower than
what we consider acceptable for human
beings we have to House people in
conditions that we see as fit for human
occupation the problem is is to clear
the backlog
um rather than lower our standards this
is all about the numbers it is about the
government being able to say that they
have removed people from hotels but in
order to do that I would say we need to
do it in a humane way we shouldn't be
lowering our standards in order to do
that we are we need to treat these
people as human beings the way that we
would treat any other human beings in
this country okay Jenny thank you Alex
is nodding but we're not going to have
time to to go to him before uh the Break
um we will come right back to you on uh
many other stories coming up could AI
disrupt the next U.S election that's on
the front of the Ft we'll discuss that
and more next
[Music]
welcome back you are watching The Press
preview still with me Jenny cleeman and
Alex Dean let's have a look at the
guardian and this story about
kieva repelling defenses from Russia
this is after an attack on Cave one of
the the biggest assaults since last year
Alex
yeah we've got a good on the guardian of
putting this on the front page and I
some people will feel that they are
ukrained out and we've got to keep
talking about this and talk about
Russia's totally unjustified invasion of
Europe's biggest country of its ongoing
atrocities inflicted on a people who did
nothing to deserve what's happening and
now we see
um Putin thrashing ground increasingly
desperate I think it was seen uh in the
face of the setbacks that he and his
armed forces have suffered uh and just
dropping bombs on civilians in Ukraine's
Capital uh it's wrong we've known it's
long wrong for a very long time we've
got to keep saying it's wrong until it
stops
yes Ukraine claiming to have neutralized
the kremlin's most potent Hypersonic
weapon Jenny
yes and this is of course symbolically
incredibly important for uh ukrainians
and the fact that Keith facing such an
onslaught a Relentless uh following
zelenski's trip to Europe
um managed to really repel some very a
very serious arsenal of weapons as Alex
says it you know the Kremlin is is
getting desperate we had a very scaled
down uh Victory Day Parade we had those
very strange reports a couple of weeks
ago about
um attacks on the Kremlin which either
look like um you know Ukraine is able to
get
um weapons very very close to uh Moscow
or um or it looks like you know they're
a sort of desperate uh false flag
operations in place there goodness knows
what's going on in in Putin's Alex is
absolutely right he is Reckoning on a
weariness among Ukraine's allies and uh
for the money to cease to flow to
Ukraine and for uh and I know this is
what Donald Trump wants is you know
Donald Trump says he could end the war
uh in in a day and that would be by
basically forcing Ukraine to seed land
to uh to to Moscow we we can't allow
that this is a completely outrageous
Invasion and you know they just have to
keep on keeping on and we have to keep
on caring about it so it's a good thing
it's on the front page
let's move on to the financial times
Alex and this story about uh chat GPT
their chief executive Sam Altman
um appearing before Congress and
actually requiring more regulation which
are quite unusual for someone who's
created the technology to be actually
saying we need more regulation
that's right it was a very enlightening
session in
um in giving evidence and anyone lucky
enough to have seen your piece of Matt
before we came on air we'll have seen
that this is a an unusual position taken
by Chief Executive I suppose there are
two different kinds of stories you can
have with this kind of robots take over
the world uh headline the first is chief
executive says everything's fine so you
say how deluded they are and the the
other one is legit executive says yes
you're right and they're actually going
to take over everything we should be
worried about it and you say gosh we
were right all these things are terrible
and this was option b this is the
business that invented uh the chat or AI
uh business concern uh saying you're
right it may well become a an issue of
significance and something to worry
about not least has has been set out in
a number of the pieces these computers
are increasingly thinking like we do
they're able to rationalize reason and
give answers and display what in other
circumstances might be considered to be
emotion uh but I suppose the most
proximate thing that the Americans are
thinking about this being uh their focus
and let's not be yes be not be unfair it
matters for the world so it's an
understandable Focus it's the
presidential election coming up and
people asking uh chat Bots uh chat.ai
what what should you what do you think
about the election that's uh forthcoming
the answers to that will be very
important for the next presidential
election yes indeed and uh Sam Altman
saying that when Photoshop came onto the
scene a long time ago for a while people
were really quite fooled by photoshopped
images and then pretty quickly developed
an understanding that images might be
photoshopped this will be like that but
on steroids so certainly concerns about
the implications for the US elections
Jenny
yes I mean gosh I think that's a
terrible comparison to me because what
Sam Altman went on to say is you know
we've now become quite canny about
Photoshop and how images can be altered
but we've also become quite canny about
the damage that photoshop can do in
terms of normalizing certain body images
or certain kinds of plastic surgery and
inflated lips and unrealistic body sizes
it's actually done quite a lot of damage
I think we need to put this in context
here there is a very large number of
very uh senior entrepreneurs in Silicon
Valley including Elon Musk who signed a
a letter a thousand of them signed a
letter calling on the development of AI
to be stopped and what Sam Altman is
saying is against the backdrop of that
kind of backlash he's not saying we
should stop what we're doing he said
there should be regulation he said there
should be warnings like there is on on
nutritional labels on of food I think
basically he wants license to continue
he wants to make sure that there is the
legitimate skepticism that there should
be but I don't think he's necessarily
doing this out of any desire to save the
world he's doing this I have a desire to
save his business and save his job and
yes you know it'll be very worrying if
this can interfere with elections it's
got enormous potential but we do need to
make sure that whatever restrictions and
regulations are there are Global because
it doesn't matter what we decide we're
going to do if Russia and North Korea
they're going to carry on technology
Jenny and Alex thank you so much